it's completely fictional it is not me
there's some elements that that are
truthful as it really is fantasy if you
will culminating from whatever the
perception has been in the media the
internet whatever
blips in
my life that have occurred that have
gone public as as a result of being in
the public eye so tell us about making
the rock
started really having fun with adding
little easter eggs from his films
there's a great shot in the movie of
pedro diving in under the water and
grabbing nick that's from leaving las
vegas one of my favorite sets i call it
a dream sequence
where nico's cage goes into like a
german expressionism
type environment and so we had to create
a whole sequence of german expressionism
film which really kind of
is a complete segue from the beautiful
mayaka spain into dark
german expressionism we had to recreate
them in old nicholas cage films so we
have all these like
strange sets that are old niko's cage
films nick is such a student of film and
he's made a conscious decision to go
away from naturalism because you watch
films now it's everything's feels so
naturalistic for him to go you know what
no i disagree like i can create a crazy
over-the-top character and it can have
as much truth as your most grounded
indie drama so which i think is another
thing that makes him so kind of unique
the narrative is unique it goes through
all kinds of twists and turns that are
unusual for a studio film this movie is
taking risks i want the audience to see
something new
and to be inspired by it the way they
were with face-off but in the context of
a comedic narrative
you